the shooting here is reigniting calls to
debate the nation's gun laws before the
massacre we spoke with Republican
Congressman Steve Scalise about gun
control
last week's interview for 60 minutes was
his first since he was critically
wounded in June by a gunman at a
congressional baseball practice in a
portion you did not see on 60 minutes
the House Majority Whip stated his
support for gun owners rights which are
now a victim of gun violence yeah but
I'm also saved by weltering people who
had guns to shoot back and whatever the
weapons gonna be I mean if it's it's not
gonna gun it'll be a hand grenade or
it'll be a knife for an axe you know I
think what's important to focus on is
that we have strong rights in this
country and you know we were protected
by them do you think all congressmen and
women should be able to have concealed
carry permits I'm a strong believer in
concealed carry legislation it comes
with proper training and I do think it's
important to remember that if you're
gonna have a firearm it's it's important
that you know how to use it and how to
protect your family so that doesn't get
into the wrong hands
but it's it's every day in America you
see people use their firearms to protect
them against a criminal do you wish
you'd had a gun um you know I'm on a
baseball field playing you probably not
going to be putting a putting a sidearm
on when you're when you're fielding
balls but a you know would have been I
think it would have been a disaster if
if the security detail wasn't there with
their weapons to to take down the
shooter
you know it's important to point out
that with Scalise and what happened that
was with a rifle that in ten minutes
four people were shot in this instance
the gunman had at least two fully
automatic weapons that had been modified
to make them fully automatic and then
amout of damage he was able to carry out
in ten minutes
truly unimaginable from those those
rooms just above my shoulder so but the
reason we played part of that Scalise
our discussion is because being a victim
of gun violence does it change kind of
the debate now on Capitol Hill in
Congress will they look at policy
solutions and those are going to be some
of the questions that are that are
moving forward Jeff and there's also the
question of how he got that Arsenal into
a hotel room apparently without raising
much suspicion or thank you